man that was uh interesting to watch
last night right i mean
we saw start first half it was like wow
good quarterback play
this looks pretty fun to watch second
half was a totally different game
and the bucks are one of those teams
where i don't know it just
it seems like i i i don't know how you
feel can't get a feel for him
every time i think oh they got it here
we go
i see the talent and the potential and
they look like one of the better teams
they come back the next week and lay an
egg and where you go
uh i don't know i guess they don't have
it all together there are issues so
they're one of those teams that's
very hard to figure out this year
let me just say this i got a pleasant
surprise last night
after the game ended because i looked at
our picks
for last week and i was impressed that
we
both had picked the exact score that the
rams would put up with 27.
i had 23 for the bucks not 24. mr holden
won by one point you had 20 for the
bucks
and then i was informed that there was
an accounting error
i was informed that after a further
audit of the
ballot counting process as it relates to
our
selections somebody had transposed your
numbers you actually picked the bucks to
win so you actually
didn't sweep me for last week it was
five and one
not five and oh so take that
but that gave me a nice little boost
last night i was feeling good
i didn't get swept by sims i got one
game right
that he got wrong sorry i'm in an extra
better mood today at least better mood
than i was well
you know i thought hey i mean i kind of
like the guy
it's thanksgiving week let me throw him
a bone here
let me ride this brady bandwagon
and give him a chance well no but really
i thought the bucks would win
i did you know i thought the bucks would
play a style of football that we saw
last week where we were so impressed
with the carolina panthers where it was
a little bit more through the run
and the two tight ends again you know so
that's where it's weird too
with the bucks it's just like how are
they how are they going to play what is
their style
that's where i'm quite kind of not sure
it's like last night they reverted a
little bit back to the
you know new orleans tom brady game plan
a little bit where they were gonna
you know appease all the weapons and
we're gonna get everybody the ball but i
don't know if that's necessarily the
best way for the bucks to win football
games and go to a super bowl
yeah you know and that's a good point
it's almost like they got drawn
into this let's show what we can do
under the lights in prime time the
narrative that hashtag tommy can't get
the ball down the field and
oh he can't get the ball down the field
he was one for nine on throws of 15 or
more yards with two interceptions let's
hear from
head coach bruce ariens and hashtag
tommy on
last night's bad showing by the tampa
bay buccaneers
everybody's disappointed you know we
played a game that we just didn't make
quite enough plays to win
everybody's ready to play i mean
we just played a good football team and
we didn't make enough plays to win but
nobody's heads down we got a big one
coming up next week so we know where we
stand and
next game's even bigger you know tonight
was
was very inefficient did not a very good
job during the second half defense
played great
kept coming up with huge stops getting
us the ball back and um
offensively we just didn't make just
couldn't make the plays that were
necessary to
be efficient and we had plenty of
chances so
um got to get them fixed
i'm telling you brady's hair gets a
shade darker every week just an
observation another observation
do you see bruce with his play wristband
that's like that's the equivalent of the
player showing up in uniform
for the post-game press conference
seriously just in case he's got to call
one more play and throw a number out
there or something
um you know yeah the the bucks
the way they played i mean yeah sloppy
certainly um inconsistent like we've
talked about like really what is their
what is their mantra what is their
identity on the offensive side of the
ball i don't really know right now
you know that's where i think it's a
little bit all over the place and then
you see yesterday
yeah it became a little bit in you know
bradyville
short passes we can't push the ball down
the field
and that's where i'm just like mike you
know
two things jumped out to me about the
game last night that didn't bro
tom brady first off seen docile for a
game where
things were big and whatever else i just
thought tom brady like where was the
fire that we usually see
i i don't know maybe that was just me
but i you know usually he
starts swearing on the sidelines and
gets people going i felt like he was a
little off that way
but the other thing i came to last night
the style of play where they're going to
put him in shotgun and expect him to
make plays to do all that
that's over like you know tom brady is
at 43
he's not going to carry your team doing
that stuff anymore
they they can't play that style of
football you know
he can't move group brian griese showed
a package of pressure on tom brady
and i wanted to go where's the pressure
he's standing in the pocket patting the
ball three times
but you know he can't move he can't do
anything and i just don't know if it's
in him anymore to carry the team against
those great
defenses the better defenses and that's
where i don't understand the shotgun
throw at every play approached by the
bucks
in certain weeks sorry for the long talk
there no no no
and he got banged around a good bit
again i think this tension
of trying to prove right that they can
stretch the field
yeah may have infected this week's game
plan
bruce erins was asked last night after
the loss whether or not
he would consider taking over play
calling from byron leftwich
and you know i no that hadn't been even
on the radar screen before but i think
it speaks to what you're saying they got
away from what
works they're they're getting caught up
in the moment aryan said no
this isn't on the coaching it's on the
players executing they need to
provide more time to tom brady he blamed
the first interception on brady getting
hit
he called the second interception a bad
read which is what it was and brady
said the same thing and you're right the
fire wasn't there
and you know they they
the bucks are now one and three in prime
time but i think
the bigger issue is that
they're one in four in big games yeah
cause i it take the giants win it
right out of the mix that's not a big
game all due respect to the giants
but in the big spot games the 4 25 p.m
eastern games or the prime time games
their only win
was against green bay green bay packers
once they were down 10 nothing
every other time they've been in that
big spot it's a loss
to the saints week one three times now
in prime time to the bears
to the saints again and last night to
the rams and they got they've got
the chiefs coming up this sunday at 4
25 pm eastern and they are staring down
the barrel of another loss
which will drop them to six and five
they
are losing their big games yeah no
six and five they're six and five seven
and five
seven and five oh all right well six
minutes remember they're having that
yeah that's right it's late late
it's all right all good okay seven and
five but regardless they're still
they're still in uh danger of uh
of uh well definitely not winning the
division i i already can congratulate
the new orleans saints
on winning the nfc south that that ship
has sailed
for the buccaneers no pun intended now
they just have to jock you for wild card
position and then they have to see
what what assignment they're going to
draw two three
two seed three seed four seed who they
gonna have to play on the road
in the opening round of the postseason
yeah well you know
you want to win of course to get in the
playoffs and then you know as we've
discussed i think off air a little bit
you'd love to be that number five seat
in the playoffs this year
you know the to be that team that okay
we didn't win division
we don't get to host the game but we get
to go to philly and play them
out of all the teams that's what you'd
want this year or whoever comes out of
the nfc's how dare i say it's philly
like it's lock and
locked in there i mean who knows so yes
you're going to be playing a lesser team
seattle right now is looking their chops
going oh wow we're all right we're not
winning the division but
on the road whatever against the nfc
east we like that
but yes the tampa bay bucks right now
you know mike
i that first off what you hit on to
start there i mean
agreed you know that first interception
trying to throw the post down the middle
that was totally uh a week of hearing
talk through the media talk heads people
like us
all the focus on hey don't listen to us
mike evans has been open down the
field yeah they listen they do and you
know it and
and that that to me was forced at no
point was chris godwin open
like god went through his hand up too
and i want to be why are you throwing
your hand up the guy's got you
beat right now he's still a step in
front of you and then brady just made
his mind up
like i'm throwing it it was open all
week in practice
i'm gonna get everybody off my back and
you know to say that yeah he got hit as
he was throwing but this is to me again
and i know i seem like a tom brady but a
tom brady hater but i don't really care
i keep it real with everybody
you know he's allowed to slide and move
out of the way every now and then
you know the the rules haven't changed i
checked the rule book i know he's tom
brady and we're not allowed to say
anything about him
but every other quarterback in football
would have been told
hey you need to slide and then throw the
ball you know but we make up excuses for
him on tv
everything like that and you know that
that was pitiful play last night there's
no other way to say that about brady and
the bucks and the way they played that
football game
especially in the second half i mean
it's almost like he was trying to throw
his way onto someone's top 10
quarterback list not that they pay
attention to that either
and and then and then there was that
weird moment
in the second half when it felt like the
dam was about to break
for the rams yeah and brady had the ball
in the end zone and it happened so
fast and the ball was out and they blew
it dead
and i wasn't happy with the ruling on
the field i wasn't happy frankly with
the way the broadcast handled it i
wasn't happy with john perry's
explanation i wasn't happy with
the fact that the ruling on the field
was upheld with hardly any analysis or
discussion
or common sense what that was a fumble
he got a lot of people
he just got lucky i mean that it was
close but that was a superstar call
which is bs because a lot of other
quarterbacks don't get that
i don't get that and john perry damned
the last time the rams played the
buccaneer i mean
tom brady and then they were in the
super bowl he yelled at aaron donald for
tackling tom brady too hard so
they're all pretty mcgreasy went to
college with brady it was excuse after
excuse after excuse for tom brady last
night that's all i heard
excuse excuse blah blah blah blah but
yeah that was a big moment certainly
that really was i mean that that could
have could have cost on the football
game but
either way yeah even in that moment the
pr the pressure
i understand it was around people who
are around him there
but this is why to me the the tampa bay
bucks can't play that
you know shotgun we're gonna drop back
and let you know rely on brady
you know they need to do other things to
keep people off of brady brady can't
move like he used to
this isn't the this isn't the new
england system where mcdaniels and
belichick have 97 million ways to throw
the ball six
seven yards and let brady dissect people
and get the ball out of his hands
quickly
there's some of that but it's not all
there
and that to me is the other thing too
that's you know kind of lost in
translation
still the merging of that offense with
the aryans left witch offense
and left witch and aryans you know mike
they're not that way
they're not they're not famous for
having offenses of going 12
place 80 yards and we're surgical you
know bruce
is you know no risking no biscuit he's
more famous for
you know five play 80 yard drives where
on on one or two plays it was a 30 or 40
yard type
gain so i still think they're trying to
hash those issues out too and that's
where i think it's a detriment
to think that they can just put tom
brady back there and let him toss it all
around the lot
all game long especially against the
better teams in football
is it simple enough to look at this and
say that brady understood it's a big
spot
remember two years ago that monday night
before thanksgiving
it was the rams and the chiefs it was
that classic
game that everyone was buzzing about the
rest of the week
do you think brady kind of willed byron
leftwich
into dialing up those plays is it is
that rather than
sticking to what worked last week right
where
you run the ball run the ball run the
ball and throw it efficiently off of
play action
brady wanted to come out and be a
gunslinger i mean really is that is that
how it happens
does it become the star court and i feel
like we've had this conversation before
where the star
quarterback overpowers the coaching
staff to do
something that isn't in the coaching
staff's interest because the star
quarterback wants it that way no
no doubt you know he'll you know that
does go on
he could let it be known without you
know you know putting a stake in the
ground or planting a flag in the ground
that
hey i'm not comfortable with these type
of plays i like these type of plays all
of that last week in the carolina game
even though the stats were good right
you know there was a number of big
throws down the field that were missed
so maybe there was some talk there about
you know again that's not my mo that's
not what i'm great at this point in my
career
you know i don't know but what i found
fascinating just
just purely from the football matchup
aspect of it too
was going man the rams their defense
they're predicated on speed and running
around
and the pass rush and doing all that and
to me that's where i was like
the bucks are kind of playing right into
their hands they're playing a rams type
of game
the rams struggle when it kind of
becomes ugly and you know you play them
in a phone booth and do that type of
stuff
but to throw the ball this is the second
best pass defensive football it's the
number one defense in football
you know if there's anything that to
slow down aaron donald in that rush it's
been run game and teams like that so
that to me is where i tend to think
what you're saying might be true that
yes there was a lot of talk about no i
like to do this and i want to throw
these type of throws
and i don't necessarily want to do that
double tight end play action hold the
ball
type of offense and i just wonder if
there's a butting of the heads there in
that
in that department ronald jones had 10
rushes for 24 yards
2.4 yards man carrie leonard fournette
had seven for 17
2.4 yards per carry and then antonio
brown had the one
other rushing attempt one attempt one
yard on a jet sweep they seemed on one
drive to really be trying to get the
ball to him
over and over again and that didn't give
them the sparkle though he was targeted
13 times more than anyone else last
night by tom brady eight catches for 57
yards
mike evans was a beast in the first half
and then they
they kind of got away from him i mean
you see what he can do
he had that aj brown moment to get to
the end zone
i i think his mentality was i get the
ball so rarely this year in comparison
to how i used to get it
i'm making the most out of it every time
i get it in my hands get out of my way
i'm scoring yeah
i mean i think there's probably a little
bit of that aspect yes
you know he's getting covered by a
really good player and jaylen ramsey
that was a fun duel to
watch and yeah brady has been unable to
kind of feed him consistently
throughout the year and i think there's
been frustration i know there's been
frustration down there about that
and you know i think again that plays
into the whole conversation that we were
talking about once again
you know evans his game is not five and
six yard type throws and doing that
his game is 15 yard in cut 20 yard out
route
you know 25 yard crossing route poster
out down the middle
deep curls things like that and those
aren't things that seem to be
in brady's wheelhouse right now too so
there's a disconnect there with
you know mike evans his skill set what
brady wants to do
how the offense is being called uh but
you know
either way we're sitting here talking
about the bucks we need to probably give
the ram some more love because sean
mcvay and that damn team
they're just tough and ready all right
you don't want to go yet okay well
it's it's more fun to talk about the
best i like scottie miller has become
scotty miller's become the forgotten man
in that passing game
he's the guy who basically has fallen
off the face of the earth now that
antonio brown
is in the mix gronk only had two catches
last night for all the throws that tom
brady had
well a lot of them weren't completed 48
passes but 26 completions he had a 62.5
passer rating thanks to two
interceptions and a fairly low
uh completion percentage in comparison
to what we're seeing now we've seen guys
65 70
right yeah and and and i really do feel
like he wanted to showcase himself
on a big night big spot a big weekend
patrick mahomes played the night before
kyla murray and russell wilson were in
prime time on thursday night
surely these guys think of things like
that there is an
element of vanity as evidence ever
darkening hair
there is an element of that for tom
brady and i i think that took over last
night
and that's where bruce arians has to
really
assert himself he can't just sit back in
the golf cart and fold his arms
and let it all unfold he needs to spot
when one of these weeks it feels like
maybe tom
is trying to bend it more towards
something that isn't going to work
right and and and now going into this
game against the chiefs
on a short week i think it's incumbent
on aryans
to say look we have to figure out what's
going to work against this defense
and it's not going to be tom brady
throwing the ball 48 times
period no exactly right there there's
gonna have to be
maybe a moment of reckoning where they
finally just sit down
i don't know what's going on there in
that conversation but all i can
say is from what i see on film and
watching last night
to me there does seem to be a disconnect
about where the offense wants to go
and what they're doing and like we
talked about no identity
and mike everything you're saying i mean
to me everything aligns to
a little bit of that you know just hey
just let me get in the shotgun and throw
it and i'll pick them apart and do those
type of things well
hey the rams don't ever blitz they're
phenomenal in the secondary
you know brandon staley the defensive
coordinator i mean he's one of those
guys to say you know watch out he's
gonna be a head coach in two years
okay he's killing it that that wasn't
the way to beat them and do that and
that's where i just think when
you know you get back to it that's where
i go yeah is brady getting
such influence on the game plan that
it's
you know taking away maybe from what
leftwich and bruce arians want to do i
don't know the answer to that but what i
see on the field
it does tell me that i think there's a
little bit of an issue or
a clash of styles there and it
ultimately may not be an
issue that is going to be addressed by
bruce arians
there's a belief in tampa that
everything
this year is about making sure brady
chooses to play
next year when they can sell tickets
when they can fill the stadium yeah when
they can
truly embrace the presence of tommy that
they haven't been able to embrace
this year among all the many cruel
ironies of the pandemic
the buccaneer is that a team that's had
serious trouble
reaching capacity over the past 15 years
they finally have a reason for people to
flood the the box office and show up
and fill the stadium and they're not
able to do it they want to be able to do
it next year
so let's keep tommy happy so he chooses
to play for us again next year and that
may be the thing
that overtakes whether or not you beat
the rams or beat the chiefs or even make
the playoffs
because next year's going to be the big
promotional push to make
as much money as possible and the hell
with whether or not
we actually are any good we just want to
sell all the tickets
sell all the jerseys and make all the
money there's nothing wrong with that no
nothing wrong with that no
they don't want us to peel back and tell
you that's the way it is folks they just
want us to sit here and say football is
family
they want to make money and having tom
brady as the quarterback next year is
going to ensure
that the buccaneers will make a hell of
a lot more money than they're making
this year
because next year they're going to fill
that stadium every week if tom comes
back
yeah i listen mike i mean you're right
there's there's definitely that aspect
that goes on and
this this aspect specifically to this
football team because of all the things
you mentioned you're right
and they're starving and starving
for franchise quarterback down there in
tampa bay i mean they
love the bucks it's a great fan base
yeah it might not be
rich and be able to buy luxury sweets
and do all that but they love it
and you know they were tortured with
people like me as their franchise
quarterback for years and years and they
finally got a guy there that's the real
deal
and they i it's okay i'll go there
uh you know me like i said i keep it
real no matter what even is
talking trash about myself all right
let's uh
throw some praise oh hey rams good job
last night we got to go to commercial 23
minutes
now let's talk about the rams for a
little bit let's first hear from coach
sean mcvay about the performance of the
side of the ball that he typically has
no involvement in whatsoever the defense
defensively a lot of confidence i
thought our defense played outstanding
really the one drive they ended up
getting was a result of
the turnover from the offense and um you
know they just continue to do such a
great job of being able to settle in
obviously tom has such great command you
have a lot of respect for their
perimeter players and
you see why they've given so many people
problems but wasn't nervous was uh was
more confident but uh
just seeing those guys come through in
the clutch was was big time for our team
i don't know what they're putting in his
gatorade i wish i had that energy
he especially especially at midnight
he's he's like you know he's like a
gruden or anything like we've always
said he's just he's a psycho in a good
way
he loves it he eats it up he's probably
up already right now
like breaking down the film and being
like hey play 69 man we got to get this
better next week we got to play better
i mean he's he loves it he lives it and
that's it shows
their football team every week you know
we talk about it
they always show up they're always ready
to compete it might not always be the
prettiest football game or whatever
but they are never asleep at the wheel
and never not ready to compete and bust
you in the mouth and that's because they
got a psycho like you just saw there
that brings energy every day
we keep looking for a complete team a
team that gets it done on both sides of
the ball and even though the rams
offense isn't as
electric as it was a couple of years ago
the defense really has improved remember
in the offseason they let wade phillips
go and we're like what in the hell are
the rams thinking wade phillips
defensive mastermind
what are you doing you're taking a step
back here your team's not going to be
any good this year and
they have just kind of quietly plugged
away plugged away it's going to be hard
to hide now yeah that they are
in first place in the division and look
at where they
are from a defensive standpoint
points allowed per game second in the
league total yards allowed per game
first in league they're in the top five
in all those categories the only thing
they're not in the top five and the
total takeaways with 15.
the takeaways will come though as teams
get more desperate they had those two
last night
and and this is an ingredient you know
we're we know that in the afc
it's the steelers and the chiefs or the
chiefs then the steelers
in the nfc we don't know no we don't
changes every week right and it's kind
it's the it's the saints now but the
rams
are there they're coming you're right
and you know not long ago it was the
seahawks and it was the bucks then it's
the packers
but uh right now it's the saints with
the rams maybe
not even not even behind 1a and 1b
saints and rams right now
with the saints obviously holding the
edge because they're eight and two but
uh the the rams are a team that needs to
be taken seriously they still have two
games against the cardinals coming up
which should be great games and uh uh
the rams have an opportunity to take off
in that division
yeah they i mean they do they got you
know they got everything you need to to
be a real contender
get to the super bowl do all that i mean
we've had this conversation you know
like you said weekly about the nfc
what teams are the most complete you
know who's really that way there's
there's flaws with
you know green bay seattle the rams
you know mike really like what what what
is it
what would you say is their biggest flaw
i mean
again i'm gonna sound like a hater here
but i think that probably the biggest
flaw is a little bit of just
i'm a little scared of jared goff at
times i mean he didn't exactly make me
feel warm and cozy last night the
numbers are gonna look good
but the way he played in the second half
was certainly a little shaky there
but after that okay and i'm not like
terribly scared about him either i mean
i still i know it's not
like perfect last night but still we
know they can win and get to a super
bowl with him and do those type of
things
after that i just go man there's there's
not a real glaring weakness to any
area of their football team and that you
know speaks to mcveigh
and like you said brandon staley what
he's doing on that defensive side of the
ball
it's creative it's sound they don't ever
have to blitz
so they always got just the four russian
and seven back in coverage
and you see it gave brady has seen every
defense in the world that gave him
issues last night so
uh they're a major player and you're
right we probably need to take him a lot
more seriously and give him a lot more
love than we have been
and the question with goff was
two years ago and continues to be will
he make the big play in the big
spot we broke it down 50 different ways
when brandon cooks was wide ass open as
bruce arians would say in the end zone
on a play that they used in the first
half of the super bowl they used it in
the second half when clearly they spent
some of that 25 minutes
telling him we're going to do it again
he's going to be open again and this
time we're going to score a touchdown
can he be counted on to make the big
throw in the big spot just like
garoppolo last year
and and that's that's the question right
and maybe you don't need the big throw
in the big spot
if your defense is that good and your
offense is a is as efficient as it was
last night 51 passes 39 completions
he hit robert woods 12 times cooper cup
11 times
the the average air yards was five
per throw so it wasn't a lot of stuff
down the field and one thing sean mcvay
said they were hoping to have a
breakthrough with explosive plays
you don't need them if you if you have
the receivers who can take the short
pass
and take it for 10 or 15 yards after the
catch yeah and puff up the quarterback
stats
you don't need that if it's there take
it
but at some point they're going to need
goff to make a big play on his own
it's going to be third and five down
three
points with you know two minutes left
sure can he convert on that
that third down keep a drive alive
whatever the case may be they're gonna
need him to make a big throw at some
point
and uh the question is will he step up
this time well those two years since he
didn't make the big throw in super bowl
53 will that will that
iron itself out when it's time for him
to do it again yeah so uh
and he's still look he's playing
extremely well the whole team's playing
extremely well
right but to the extent that every team
has a flaw i agree with
you can you count on goff when the game
or the season
is riding on his ability to make that
threat yeah that's the that's the big
question i mean he
he you know he he runs that offense he
does a lot of good things he's got a lot
of
pressure on him they're always trying to
change plays do things like that
so you're right it's not all about him
having to deliver plays there's so many
other things about the offense and he
just needs to be the
the commander of the ship there really
and make sure it all goes the right way
and there's encouraging things about
last night too i mean of course
hey you see the numbers hey throwing
down the middle of the field the drop
back pass game and stuff
certainly had some big moments there
that was encouraging
and you know mike i don't even know it's
like you know we've seen him delivering
the big moments we've seen him not
deliver in the big moments
i think the big thing i take away from a
game last night is just like
not that you have to deliver in those
moments but man
don't deliver those type of mistakes in
those moments that to me was a little
bit of the disheartening thing there
and that comes about with him every now
and then where you just go man
you played too much football to make
that mistake or
panic on a screen pass and throw the
ball eight feet to the right of the
running back because they're just
directly to jason pierre
like they're right around you and you
don't know and you're just gonna throw
it
and then you know even the second
interception no good play by the safety
but there you know there's rules with
quarterbacks certain coverages you don't
throw certain routes against
you know this coverage in cut versus a
quarter safety
it's a no-no i've thrown my
interceptions off that i certainly
haven't played you know like jared goff
but
you know those are just ones where you
just go man come on
you know it's a defensive game their
offense is incapable of doing anything
right now
don't do that type of stuff you know
normally he doesn't he's still a real
good quarterback but yes i
tend to still question whether he can
carry them
when need be in a big moment certainly
and and those mistakes if the tampa bay
offense had been
hitting on all cylinders last night
would have been fatal definitely that
was the difference and again you got to
give credit to the rams defense but this
that the bucks got away
from what they did so well against the
carolina panthers
and that really it just felt like it was
sputtering that it was grasping that it
just couldn't make it happen
in the second half and it still was a
closer game
than i thought it was going to be and i
i keep going back to that play i
just there aren't many moments like that
in the course of a football season where
while watching a prime time game i'm
like are my eyes working is my brain
working but that that
fumble was a fumble that play that was
quickly called incomplete remember we
hear all the time let the play go before
you blow the whistle where did that
happen
yeah last night it didn't i mean that
should it we got an exciting finish out
of it but it should have been rams up
14. that probably would have been it for
the tampa bay buccaneers well
unfortunately and i know you've heard me
say this like during sunday games
the athletic strong young quarterback
gets no calls when it comes to that type
of stuff getting hit
unnecessary roughness the pocket i can't
move type quarterback
seems to always get the benefit of all
those calls
that bothers me a little bit you know
and i'm talking about you know apples to
apples yes they're in the pocket people
are around them
it's like the young stud the referees
are like ah he can take it
and then some of the older he can't move
there hey you better be careful he can't
get out of the way so quick
that's not nice and that's bs that's bs
and i feel like between brady being a
superstar
and that aspect that's what happened
last night remember when cam newton
claimed that ed hoculey said to him
you're not old enough to get those
right right yes exactly cam newton's the
perfect one i mean
he people head hunt him and everyone's
just like ah
he's okay you can't hurt him he's a
greek god
yeah meanwhile he's hurt every single
year because he keeps getting hit and
everybody thinks he's indestructible
including him who would you rather face
in the playoffs the rams or the bucks oh
uh the bucks right now
definitely yeah the bucks the their
defense you know again
last night dominant in the second half
but like
you know this weird thing of where they
play a little bit like
hesitant preventish early in games and
then it takes them like okay this is
what they're doing and then they get
aggressive but the inconsistencies of
the bucks and all that
and i think just the issues on the
offensive side of the ball yeah i'd
rather play them right now than the rams
the rams as you talked about there's
just not many weaknesses to them
all right your defense is in i gotta
make a stop situation would you rather
the quarterback be tom brady or jared
goff
i'd probably still go brady i probably
would yes you'd rather he be the
quarterback that you face
uh i i'd probably do the defense you got
to stop him you got it if i
he's tom brady he's the goat yeah i know
i i would no yeah
i would i would if i was you're asking
me what quarterback i'd want in a big
moment against a good defense
i would probably still want brady over
goff that's where you're at you're the
defense who you want to face
that's so you'd rather face goff than
brady is that what you're saying i
i'm sorry i didn't ask the question no
yeah i think i think so yes i think
that's right
i would i would okay brady's ability to
throw the ball
do those things i think still scares me
than golf goffs is more predicated on
you know the offense and like you talked
about it's five yards of throw
you know you see the offense sputter in
the second half a lot of that is just
because
the bucks take away all the bull crap
throws you know for lack of a better
phrase the screens the wide receiver
screens all those type of things
where you know listen i i don't put a
lot of like stock into that as far as
quarterback evaluating and go oh my gosh
what a great throw two yards behind the
line of scrimmage for a gain of 20 yards
wow you're the only guy on football that
could do that
i think brady can still rise to the
moment i do too can't
get to the moment you got to get to the
moment right that's the problem it's the
nuts and bolts
drive in and drive out throwing and
throw out where he's not
what he used to be whether that's he's
still getting comfortable
with tampa bay and their offense whether
it's the coaching
isn't as aggressive as maybe it was in
new england maybe there's
maybe there's a benefit to having a
coach who is willing
to call you out in front of the the the
your teammates relentlessly you know
it's one thing for bruce arians to
sit at a press conference and say yeah
that interception was his fault but i'm
talking about aggressive coaching
points that we'll make with everybody
and not just blaming you yeah not just
blaming you for a mistake when everyone
knows it was his
fault but telling him what he needs to
hear so he does better
the next time in designing game plans
aimed at getting the most
out of the players that he has that's
the challenge now for the tampa bay
buccaneers as they have patrick mahomes
coming to town in just five days
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports